le village de la fondation psg s'est
installé aux chaînés rocancourt le temps
d'un après-midi créée il ya vingt ans la
structure propose aux enfants de
participer à des animations pendant les
vacances scolaires
350 opérations sont réalisées chaque
année par le paris saint-germain donc ce
sont des enfants qui ont entre 6 et 15
ans qui peuvent venir avec leurs parents
leurs grands frères leurs grandes soeurs
vraiment de partager un moment en
famille et on est on est sur des publics
qui n'ont pas forcément la chance de
partir et il reste pendant toutes leurs
vacances scolaires chez eux donc il
essaie de leur groupe leur proposer un
petit moment festif ce mardi 27 octobre
une douzaine d'animations étaient au
programme
donc on doit faire la deux on doit
mettre nadal et vous n'est pas nier le
maquillage les personnes les activités
sont issus de notre projet éducatif qui
socle pédagogie qui est la culture des
quatre centres pédagogiques qui est la
culture le numérique la cité l'histoire
du club était également présenté aux
familles avec une seule des trophées
éphémère les anciens joueurs du psg
comme laurent fournier avait également
fait le déplacement
ça permet de revivre pour beaucoup dé
bon moment pour les enfants de devoir un
peu que le psg a évolué la fondation psg
devrait continuer à sillonner le
département pendant ces vacances
scolaires un nouveau village devrait
être installé à magnanville ce jeudi 29
octobre au complexe sportif irma riffaud